No are you ready mm I was ready all
right here we go whoo
okay ladies and gentlemen welcome to
your favorite podcast you know the name
[Music]
just the singing Mike and I always offer
to sing a mic to the guest what you
gotta look for a pocket spear on this
side now and Eric Griffin's got a pretty
good spot I got a hole in his ceiling
man and it's right I tried to get up the
stairs and there's water I took up the
stairs and I thought I saw his daughter
but it was neighbor it wasn't here and
now we're gonna start rapping on his
podcasts is people love the whoo whoo I
love the wood yes hashtag whoo
let's just get right into it ladies
gentlemen welcome to the podcast for the
first time I am actually a longtime fan
of this guy but welcome to the podcast
mr. Michael Rosenbaum thank you and I
didn't know you were fans he just told
me because we had done some stand-up I
was starting to do some standing out
that see you around you're always real
kind but you never came up to me man hey
I'm a fan yeah because because I you
know why is because like you're doing
the stand-up thing and I know how that
is
I know how tough it is right yeah and
then you're already in your head about
like I don't belong here everybody just
an actor and I know all the things you
were going through in your head so I was
like me not even like go into it with
you so cuz you'll find your way you know
what I mean I appreciate that I didn't
think about that till just now but
you're right if I if you came up to my
big fan then you're
like oh my god I have to be good even
better now cuz it Eric's here you know
whatever yeah yeah but I again I am a
fan you were at Lex Luthor on Smallville
for like 17 years right it felt like it
felt like a long time I think about
Smallville was always like I love the
idea that oh he's never gonna be in the
Superman suit and it's always gonna be
like the pre you know but like after
like seven years it's like bro
my kid is looking old as hell well they
David died his grave you know what
happened as I think that you know it was
always the story before the story it was
always like nil they had the rule there
was like no flights no tight right and
so that was sort of the thing and then
so with me even though I talked about
this on my podcast but people always
were like why did you leave I'm like my
contract was six years I actually did
seven right right
I didn't leave I just didn't add on
years you shouldn't want do it anymore
Kevin Smith [ __ ] I love you Kevin I've
said it before but to go every time you
hear was like yeah he left the show
leave the show I decided not to come
back yeah he just decided not to do it
anymore
well yeah I just I my obligation was
fulfilled I did what I was supposed to
do but I just was like you know I'm
ready to do some other stuff
okay this was gonna say cuz at what
point did you go kids it's like cuz one
you're not bald so I don't see it I want
you to hold it like you're like this is
a lot I have to become this character I
have to like shave my head I have to be
Lex Luthor for like it's like it's going
on six seven and then you're just like
you know what I'm done I think it was
more you know and that's the thing of
not other people come up to me go
did you were bald cap I'm like [ __ ] you
yeah I they shaved me every day right
and believe it or not I'm glad they did
because I didn't really feel like Lex
Luthor I was kept my goose ball you're
right right yeah joking I'm always with
your thesbian
yeah you know my friends are like they
couldn't believe when I got Lex Luthor
they're like come on dude and I thought
you they're gonna fire me but when I
shaved my head on set except for this
little
bump in the back I was like it even it
became more intense like I felt even
though then you know I'm single and goth
chicks like me right right more and I
was colder and when I had a head full of
makeup I couldn't lie down so a lot of
come a lot of candle for you too this is
someone I fart no no did I fart like you
would know oh did it smell but I thought
it was one of those Salmons that don't
smell what kind of Salmons don't smell
exactly did I smell up your [ __ ] this
diva comes in with I had to meet
I had to eat no I wanted to eat healthy
with salmon and potatoes nothing for me
by the way yeah but look man I cherish
it I love it I think I even love it more
now that it's gone I you know I don't
have any regrets I you know I bought my
house it the fans are spectacular I go
to conventions I was just in New Orleans
I'm going to Portland at the end of this
month in Mexico and it's like it's
endless and like you can go there and
Tom and I who's Clark Kent we we sign
autographs Tom Welling yeah right Tom
was great and we do Smallville nights we
created this thing called Smallville
nights where we do this little improv
show for die-hard fans that's and it's
it's actually really good and fun we're
a ballcap I'm ready to I'm gonna come
you mean right now
[Music]
yeah the first time but I don't know
about after that yeah so no but that's
that's amazing that you're still because
the I was on workaholics so I'm forever
gonna be Montez and you were great Lex
you did that for years seven years I was
seven years how many episodes oh did
they
I wasn't in every year bright merry but
but still it was such a like such a
jarring thing that character was so
different from everybody else that it's
like you know I walk out in the streets
and people are like this Mochis so I get
so I embraced it so what embrace so what
I'm hearing from you is that you're
gonna be Lex Luthor for a long time
listen you're okay with it yeah you know
I think you go there's some immaturity
levels let's be honest when you're I'm
still very immature for my age but like
you know your 20s I think you think
about Fame
everybody didn't know me this is so cool
and for me it was like instant
gratification and it was just like are
they like me and it's a tension and I
didn't get you know certain things just
a kid so you know these things felt real
to me
yeah and then once you start to go
through [ __ ] you live life and you
experience and you start being grateful
and taking a step back you're like god
I'm [ __ ] lucky if I'm just Lex Luthor
for the rest of my life I don't I mean
how lucky is that if I die in that you
know people you know they troll when
people will say about every actor right
right right
what are they doing what they're doing
after work of all job what's Rosenbaum
do what was his we were I was on the
biggest show on television of them yeah
and so you could only go down back when
people were actually watching TV watch
TV no social media and you know I look
back and it was in Tom and I are still
friends I'm friends with everybody on
the sex if there's one person that you
know I was friends with her and then
things happen oh yeah
so look you learn you I'm so grateful
like yeah anybody who knows me knows
that I just like it's the house that Lex
built it who cares right yeah man it's
awesome and now you know I'm also lucky
where I could I like to do the things
that I want to do and sometimes people
don't understand that but I don't know
if I'm gonna when I'm gonna die I could
die tomorrow so why don't I just try to
do everything I can now the way I want
instead of thinking I should do this
because other people think I should do
that and I'm gonna make them happy you
got to make yourself happy yeah I I
totally get you cuz like I think we're
in the same age bracket so he's like I'm
late forties me too you don't sell your
age you know who cares what your
birthday March 12th July 11 no but what
I'm saying is like you know it's like
you do what you do like you know
obviously I'm still like in this little
town house thing so I didn't I didn't
make Lex Luthor money but it doesn't
matter because let me tell you what I'm
happy I didn't mean to it's not no I'm
saying I'm happy I I like I I was always
a person I wanted to save instead of buy
something so yeah so I'm saving cuz I
like to try off I say
oh yes you say you have every penny
you've ever made it's true it doesn't
matter I was with four guys in a
one-bedroom in New York trying to become
an actor right and those are the
happiest moments of my life like and I
look back like a what made it happy it
meant you were happy because and look
Happy's kind of you know comes in and
out yeah you you you make us yeah yeah
yeah yeah but I think it's about
connection it's about people it's about
feeling like you're doing something good
and it's not about how famous you are
the money you're making it really is if
you can change people's lives or
effectively then you're here for a
reason its purpose and that's what it is
but don't you think it's like it's two
different phases of like in it I feel
like in when you were living in the
one-bedroom apartment that was the
pursuit of happiness and in that pursuit
you don't realize that that is actually
happiness you know because I have this
purpose and I'm trying to do it but then
when you actually made it isn't it
strange that you found yourself that's
when like unhappiness would filter in
like you'd be like oh I'm stuck in this
or I don't like my contract or I'm not
getting enough stuff or not being
present I'm not yeah yeah you know I go
on hikes I'm gonna name-drop I do a
thing when I name-drop what do you do
careful job you just drop something oh
so it's like so I went hiking with Jason
Patric oh you dropped oh hey Jason so
Jason's been a friend of mine and we we
go on hikes once a week that's it he has
a kid he's a great dad and we just take
a two-hour hike and we talk about life
and stuff and he said something pretty
profound and I probably won't articulate
it as well as he did but it was more or
less what he was saying is even when
you're famous when all this stuff is
going on you're look it's always the
next thing what's Matt yes what's around
the corner what is this setting that up
to be emptying myself up for this and
you're not you're not going Wow dude
this is great it's never and you have to
force yourself to do that you have to be
you have to engage you have to be force
yourself to be present and enjoy things
it wasn't it was season three of
workaholics that I thought to myself I
need to go on a vacation it was the
first vacation of my life like I
like what I paid for it let's go I will
hook a buddy of mine we went to the Cook
Islands off the coast of New Zealand
it's like that I was it it's like Hawaii
of New Zealand first day I was like oh
man and then the second day I put my
phone down third day I just was like
looking at the Sun and I go in that
light you know and I was like oh this is
what I want to do it myself so I'm
saying it's like I think we have to like
cuz we often times think I'll god I'll
never work again it's like every time
you leave a set you go well that's it I
don't think like that I used to this is
what we did I did this I did this you
know that's what we did we like okay
well this is it you know or or you stay
on a project too long because you think
if I leave this I'll never work at
anywhere else and so it's like that's
the thing that happens in our head right
right so you think well I stay three
more years man that's gonna put a lot of
money in my bra and I could live longer
I can live on it and I thought well you
just did seven years and you made decent
money
you're not like DiCaprio money not like
you're not gonna live the rest of your
life on this but you know what I should
just try to enjoy things I don't need to
do every I mean how many years do we get
and yeah every year like if you had
upset with seven years divided by 47 I
mean when I when I quit at the tide and
quit see I said I quit when I left when
you leave when my contract expired god
yeah but you didn't sign another one and
they wanted you to come back right
so I had tomatoes to-mah-toes that was
10 years ago let's say I was 35 so 7
years 35 you know that's like what a 5th
7th or 25th of your life already so when
is it enough when is you know I don't
understand and you could tell me that
I'm saying this because I not them and
I'm not rich and maybe I don't maybe
they love work but all these folks these
celebrities that have so much money like
what's-her-name who I love Patricia
Heaton uh-huh they do series and that
they were making a million in episode
and they have over hundreds of millions
of dollars there's no way I'm doing
anything for anybody with a hundred
million dollars 50 million twenty ten
million dollars I'm living my
life I'm doing what I want I'm gonna get
a movie together for a million dollars
and put all my friends in it and that's
what I did and I'm gonna you know these
are the things I just don't get it when
you I just love work I look you have a
family you have this you could travel
the world and maybe they have but it
just it always baffles me like they have
to work or they're stressed something's
going on even you know I went a lot oh
you're out too out I win the [ __ ]
Temecula lotto I'm out if I hit the
Fashion Square Mall yeah well I just but
some people like I said there are some
people who are in love with money I
think a lot of performers some of them
have come up they had tough times yeah
and you know and it's just that is
always in their head and then I guess -
there's people that just love it's not
just work don't let's not even call it
work
they love performing you know they love
being in they love being in front of the
camera 14 hours a day every day 22
episodes a year no I don't find the joy
in that would you don't well I mean look
I'm also at a place where I was young
enough where I made some money and I did
at night and I can get through but I
remember those nights and those days and
those just being like what am i doing
well no I wasn't that it was just like
hey you know I'm lucky and this is
awesome but I hope that I don't have to
I don't in its it's hard to understand
what that sounded like it it dick
because it's it's like doing something
it's great to do something cuz you'd
love it yeah right
when you're doing it and you're like
okay I'm pretty good and I'm making
money and people love me doing this but
you're like I don't know I took this I
told you what you how you've been
expressing yourself right now I already
knew this like what you're saying right
now one is I just I know that you did
not love being on being Lex Luthor on
Smallville
no no that's not what I'm saying well no
I think I'm telling up there is a point
where you were like this is there was a
point I'm great at this people love me
at this like why not you know this you
you are sports fan I mean I follow some
sports okay New York fans so it's hard
to do that but there's a guy Marcellus
Wiley he's on this show speak for
yourself I'm gonna have him on the
Podcast - but he talks a lot of he was a
great football player to the point where
he was one of the highest players paid
players in the league at a certain point
but he talks about on the show all the
time do you know he did it from he
wasn't about Championships he was about
making money I didn't need to get his
money so there are some people that like
I feel like he managed because he also
went to an Ivy League school I feel like
he was like hey I'm a physical specimen
I could play football and make a lot of
money from our family so why not do that
so I feel like that makes sense
and you're not saying yep so it's not
like he was like he he may not have
loved it as much as you know like people
think you should love it but he was like
nah I auditioned so for you it's like
hey I auditioned for this part they love
me for it
III was a kid I know Superman and it's
like this is great but it is their point
you're like why would I have chosen this
for myself well I think that yeah well I
do this is a great points and these are
therapy sessions in fact my podcast
inside of you Michael Rosenbaum I'm
telling you this is what we taught this
is we have these like sessions where I
really it became it was therapy for me
and then it became therapy for the
guests and then I get and then the
people there listening this is all it's
it's it's cool to talk about but it also
it's it's most sometimes I'm saying
no it's I'm just trying to figure it out
like I think what can I say something
before you go on yeah because I feel
like that you've dealt with this for so
long because you have people cuz like
you had some feelings about what you
said about Kevin Smith I guess I love
Kevin
no I'm sec you you you you validating
you really care about what people think
I know well I'm less but but yeah but I
do actually do like Kevin if I didn't
I'd be like [ __ ] that guy no no I know
but I'm saying but that's what I'm
saying
he's already you're so you so you're
like and you really are adamant about
saying like I didn't quit I just didn't
get my so like all those semantics that
you're like dealing with in your head
you know I'm saying to you like it's
okay to be like I got sick of it and I
didn't want to come back I don't think
anybody's gonna blame you for that no
yeah you know what I mean I don't say
that that's what it was but what I'm
saying is it's okay yes I remember the
president of Warner Brothers took me out
to dinner and he sat me down and I had
done other shows show for two years show
one year pilots just you were great as
Lex well thank you okay no no no this is
I was the president of Warner let me
know I gotta say this right now I would
be like now we gotta get him back no Lex
losers gotta come back like we can't
have and that yeah we can't not have Lex
Luthor he's you know so I get how they
were like now you know and I hope that
they threw money at you and you still
were like I have to say you know when
they threw money they it was weird it
was this conversation where he took me
to dinner and I was like looks I knew I
wasn't doing well like when he came in
what it didn't matter and let unless
honestly if they went like above and
beyond but he or say look we can um we
can't give you an increase in pay we're
just gonna give you what you were making
in season seven through that that's the
truth he just fit so they didn't offer
me an increase but it didn't really
matter I just was like you know Peter I
really respect you and I thank you for
the work and you know my grandma thinks
I'm funny and I don't know my friends
kind of think I'm funny and I think I'm
a little funny and I just did this
serious part that no one ever thought I
could do and I did it for a long long
time and I I busted my ass to the point
where I was like I was losing my mind I
mean I was losing my mind playing this
role sometimes I put so much in there
like a straitjacket yeah I put so much
into this and that's why we'll get into
that oh the whole Lex and what I play
him again all that [ __ ] because that I
go Peter I just I loved it I put
everything into it but I'm just done
yeah I am I'm just done and I want to go
out I want to go throughout the movie a
little raunchy comedy that I wrote I
want to do some yeah I just want to
start something new I'm just I feel like
and I think he did not like the answer I
was about to say yeah there's no doubt
when it mean you say no to someone that
big their ego for some reason he
couldn't understand that this was about
me it wasn't about him yeah and when and
that's sometimes hard to do in
relationships but sometimes it's like
this is about me man and I says I feel
this way don't get mad at me because I
feel this way this is how I genuinely
feel and no button and by the way you
didn't owe him that I know you know but
you this is part I could tell there just
as part of your personai get people
happy yeah try to make people understand
yeah that's part that's dude that's
sometimes there's a double-edged sword
cuz you didn't need to tell him [ __ ] you
could have just said to him I don't
wanna do this anymore
yeah
and I'm out thank you for dinner you
didn't even have to have dinner that was
a disrespectful yes and no but like but
you couldn't when he offered to dinner
you easily could have said listen I know
what you want to say and I don't want to
waste your time I respect now ulam back
I'm not coming but then what have you
said four billion in episode all right
Peter tell me what day more cows or GDR
in seas yeah you know nobody though
here's the thing too though I just
hearing just that story I I'm not trying
to like I would take offense cuz I'm
like don't tell me Lex is important to
the show and then tell me that you're
not gonna get a pay raise you know cuz
that's a bit by the way Tom attest to
this it's been the story of my life when
it comes to that sour grapes not it's
just a fact it's you know you were
talking about crisis yeah we got all
that's okay by the way there's this
great I love the CW the The CW has all
my guilty pleasures by the way I love
Vampire Diaries I loved originals and
now I'm watching legacies I love those
kind of like just non-central the flash
I love Supergirl I don't watch the flash
I don't watch arrow I really hated to to
many relationship I have a lot of those
guests like I have some well some of
those guests there's you know I just had
Morena Baccarin from Gotham and Deadpool
and she's coming on and and like so I
get a lot like Stephen Amell and
Katherine McNamara and a bunch of those
guys come on and they're great and
they're wonderful and I got text the day
that I said no to that infinite cry so
what it is is like so let they do is
they do a crossover of all the
characters so they have flat even blot
they even brought black lightning in on
the crossover episode so milking it see
they were milking it and they had all
these characters and they were any Tom
Welling did it they even brought in
Jared Aransas as Lois Lane yeah and uh
what's his name Roth from the the movies
the Superman movie Brandon Ralph
Brandon rouse right it was in it he's
been in it actually good for him and so
they had this crisis and then what the
one person they were missing was their
Lex Luthor right let me let me explain
exactly what happened I'm just gonna I
tweeted this and surprisingly I thought
I'd get lambasted but everybody was like
did [ __ ] them I appreciate this I mean
other actors I was classy about I just
said listen guys when someone I'm gonna
try to give you an analogy here but can
I can i interject container Jewish
certainly can touch your shadow no no
because with Griffin you know because I
feel you I really do yeah
don't act like you doing me a favor
before what
now I'm saying like that the the the the
DC people and then Warner Brothers they
acting like they doing you a favor
hey hey we're gonna do this thing and uh
yeah
how about we're gonna let you come play
Lex Luthor again yeah and you're like
nah [ __ ] guess what mmm sometimes you
have I'm doing you the favor yeah and
that's the truth that that's the truth I
would have been doing them a favor you
was been doing them a favor because if
see what people understand is I learned
this at it well not that long ago but
you know if you want somebody to do
something it's very simple first you'd
be kind you give them respect yeah Eric
workaholics is coming back I think
you're a fantastic actor you're funniest
[ __ ] you're stand-ups brilliant I want
to work this out I don't want to work it
out for you to come back and workaholics
would you think about it before we even
get in all the contracts and everything
yes I did that that's how they came with
me I would because because by the way if
they're talking about doing a
workaholics movie you know how they're
bringing shows back maybe Netflix it's
like yeah bring back Holly's I mean I
was already dealing with some stuff with
them like in the in the end like Comedy
Central like so we were like guaranteed
a certain number of episodes episodes of
seasons five and six right seasons no
I'm a four and five there's six and
seven they decided to cut like it was me
Jillian and Mary Beth they actually cut
our guarantee down to a certain number
of episodes respect even though we got a
raise but it was a pay cut you know just
like Manistee not making as much but but
the thing was you know why I did it cuz
they took away all the exclusivity they
said there's no exclusivity you do
whatever you want I can do whatever I
want so I was like cool and it worked
for you it worked for me I go get this
free money and then I ended up booking
another show anyway yeah you and me both
so I know what you're saying like don't
come at me like it was very simple to it
was very simple I
got a foreword from my agent and it said
Infinite Crisis we need to know today if
Michaels in or out we don't have a
script by we don't know when it's
filming but it's gonna be some time
whenever bla bla bla and this is how
much he's getting that's it
we need to know today and I it wasn't
just laughable I looked at my friends
like it didn't you know what it is it's
just it's just stupid whoever made sent
that email is just stupid first of all
you have someone call me hey he played
lex on our network for seven years some
say the best so you know what give me a
call how about you call me up as a human
being and say hey dude we're doing this
we want to include you we loved you
whatever just be if the fans love but
now you send this this is the day this
is when he's working
we want to know about it I may be [ __ ]
off yeah it was just [ __ ] off I totally
get was it was just like I left at it
yeah and by the way another part of me
is like I was Lex Luthor for seven years
there's a powerful powerful role I don't
want to play some three-line Lex in some
soup odd world I don't know what's going
on and I love all those guys and I
respect him and they're great I'm just
saying I'm not in validating because I
really like do what you got to do not
for me not right for me I don't have to
prove myself I know what I did I know
but I think that they would have had you
coming in on Supergirl though I think
they already have a Lex Luthor but today
we're gonna so they have Alexis on
Supergirl so oh that's terrible so when
I love Juncker I really knew you loved
John John was on the pockets he's great
alo he's great but just now they weren't
even gonna so you were just gonna be
like what Tom Welling was doing I saw it
you didn't miss out on [ __ ] good for you
yeah okay good for you and people asked
him would you play Lex again absolutely
in a heartbeat if it was the right thing
if you know the only thing that upsets
me truthfully is no one's ever asked me
to audition for one of these movies is
Lex Luthor the cast Eisenberg loved
Eisenberg worked him with a great actor
did a movie with him
and space love all this stuff I get it
gene Hackman's my favorite I think the
best is the best by the way I had a fan
come up to me one time he waited in line
20 minutes for a signature that goes hey
Gene Hackman was the best Lex Luthor and
I go hi know right he's like yeah but
they rarely do that anyway though by the
way don't rarely take the person front
way to smooth this like don't like that
sound don't do one more time I that's
I'm yeah let me finish that what I'm
saying is I don't care that they're of
Lex Luthor's I don't want the I'm not
asking for the role if somebody did it
for seven years and a lot of the fans
and I'm feeling it it's not like I'm
just guessing yeah I'm reading this [ __ ]
I see how much the role did for people
audition him just let me read for it let
me just show you what I could do let me
just have a read that's all I ever
wanted I don't want the role let me go
in there and [ __ ] pound your face
with some dialog the devil's advocate on
the other side of that is like I know
that lady Lex may be like yeah no it's
crossover now everybody does everybody's
what that clothes is doing TV no I'm
talking no no I'm talking no what I'm
saying is what I'm saying is you you
don't you dyslexic people know is from a
universe and and everybody knows about
that universe in their head I was
talking about the Eisenberg role no no I
understand that but what I'm saying is I
don't know if I would want a Lex that
you have stuff in your head connected to
and those things aren't there it's like
when you're watching the Marvel Universe
okay so what they did was they combined
all the movies so now in our heads the
MCU
is a complete thing so when I'm watching
a solo Thor movie and [ __ ] is going on
my mind is like where's Iron Man wears a
black widow because they're in this
universe and there's an alien attack
these people should be here okay
so that's what was wrong with dart world
so what I'm saying is if you're Lex
loser on the screen
I'm Superman's Tom Welling in my head
it's gonna be hard to agree well that
but I think that's the thought process
by it I don't know why because now I'm
more of them I mean many people would
disagree but I'm
I'm more of a man I was a kid when that
show ended many years ago so how cool
would it be is I'm a young guy I left
the show and I was what 35 you look the
same and not really but you shaved my
head you put so I'm older I got bags
under my eyes I'm a [ __ ] you know I
got experience now I gather and you put
me on that screen 0% chance of anybody
not watching it because I'm Alexis
0% yeah I know I'm saying but I get to
pet the thought prime what that I'm like
to a new generation that Olson he was he
was on a show back that he ended in 2008
for him
hey the fans or the fans well here's a
good but I think the fans disagree I
think the fans do want me okay I'm just
or at least an opportunity to do it hey
I I would have wanted you to do it but
I'm just saying I understand why they
like things where no one ever talks this
[ __ ] with me I'm just saying nobody in a
hard hard
I'm just saying nobody they did just
rarely do that it's like when they're
gonna make a flash movie they didn't ask
this guy from the TV show to be the
flash and the thing well you know but I
want you then you maybe you need to go
watry watch some scenes or I lose my
[ __ ] dude I'm with you just saying but
that's a different category III but my
old my opinion maybe this is just me
because I know how good I you know III
think I wasn't that doesn't sound humble
I don't give a [ __ ] you just told me to
be yeah yeah but you're so I'm saying
there's no reason I shouldn't be up for
that role ever you ask anybody who
watched that show I am Telling You and I
wouldn't say that unless I really
thought it and you could feel it if I
thought I'm not delusional
I'm not going like I have it's really
great in that role and like no one saw
that you weren't good I know enough over
the years from just fans and letters and
Screen Rant articles and other magazines
and deadlines saying I was the best Lex
and it's obvious that a lot of people
have this same feeling so to back my own
ass up I'm saying I'm I'm talking about
what I have felt what I feel it's just
one of those things where my confidence
inside knows and I'm by the way not
if I never play Lux again I don't care
that's not the I don't care all I'm
saying is that there's a Tara little
know if there's an opportunity or you're
auditioning a Lex Luthor you just it's
stupid not to at least have me read it's
just stupid I feel you that's all I'm
saying no no I feel ya and I appreciate
I appreciate the cloudiness
I appreciate and the openness of you
saying that you know well it's something
I've never really expressed like that
but I just feel like you know after all
this time it's it's time to like kind of
say well it's even but even like I think
that this will be good for your numbers
not jit in the podcast not just you but
I felt like you and Welling should have
been the Superman and the UH and the Lex
Luthor in the movie well I think when
they did that when they did that movie
that uh what's-his-name was in the Roth
you know yeah you know that one I just
think they made a mistake by not taking
advantage of doing a Smallville movie
right after it ended or a small bill cuz
I think it would have done really well I
talked to dwelling about like him as
Superman yeah exactly look again I don't
even I know it sounds probably um my
whole point of this thing is I know I
was Lex Luthor for seven years I know I
did a great job I'm confident my work I
know I could destroy it if it was
something more not so bubblegum anymore
yeah because when I watch stuff I don't
try not to judge but Lex I was always
methodical I was always and blessed the
writing bless you know Alan miles bless
all these guys but it was it was part of
me it was part them it was part the way
it looked but what I did I felt like it
was Lex should always be thinking ten
steps ahead of you you shouldn't be
crazy like the Joker
he shouldn't be whatever when he loses
his mind
everybody goes whoa it's like my dad
he's really quiet real corny goes I
don't want you to [ __ ] do that again
and I'm just like melting I can't even
move and Lex is like that if he's
[ __ ] finally all this stuff he's very
composed and that's how I always felt
like the character should be
everything's fine he could lie like
nobody he's brilliant and that's the Lex
Luthor that I think it will work
that's what people want to see and I
don't know whoever plays it I know
there's a lot of great actors I could
kill it yeah yeah but that's the
direction so when they when they have
that actor whoever that is the director
needs to the they're as responsible just
as much as the studio and the actor Lex
Luthor needs to be [ __ ] cool and
calculating and have just an underneath
darkness that when it comes out it is
maniacal but not flashy I want to win an
Oscar thank you what you're saying man I
like it a lot what you're saying here I
think that the DC Universe is better on
they've been better on TV because
they've just failed in the movies they
just don't watch a lot of stuff I felt
like there that these trust me take it
from me they're just there for DC movies
the DC movies
I don't know Batman Wonder Woman was
okay Batman's about Superman's I'm
talking about since since the Christian
but impossible and by the way with Heath
Ledger dying that dead but that monkey
wrenched the whole thing I wasn't a fan
of the third one I thought that was a
ridiculous half face so what's that
guy's name yeah yet - two-face and they
just they unfortunately that happened
and it was unfortunate thing for you
know of course Heath Ledger was great
but it just in terms of for the movie
makers that like was Dan that sucked for
what the way they the direction is are
gonna go so so after that movie then
they started all this other stuff and
look look they can't keep Batman they
can't keep a Superman
you know but to defend them I was just
saying this I'll defend them and I'll
defend you know Marvel movies only
because it just takes one
it takes one Travolta in a Tarantino
movie to put him on top it takes one
great DC movie to change the whole
landscape and when they get the right
people when they get the right script
and they don't need have the desire or
have the they're not what's the word
when you're compulsive like it's it's it
feels like I had up a movie that every
three months what they were 20 months
three months do you remember when Batman
came out we knew he had a six months or
a year before maybe Back to the Future
came out or these big movies and now
every [ __ ] a week there's one of
these movies and it's like it's just
like it's just the same thing so there's
a few that are great
when you're throwing out the same [ __ ]
all the time not [ __ ] but sit on it on
it develop develop develop for years
like they used to me that's what the
Marvel Universe did I mean Marvel did it
right
they might look it Marvel has done it
right no they planned it out it was like
they they thought they were leading up
to built up to it right they had a great
actor Robert Downey jr. was just
absolutely fantastic he carried the
whole thing and then these other people
caught up with him and they they even
made a couple of [ __ ] movies in the
middle but it's serviced their overall
story it's the sputnik mentality you
don't make that up it's the sputnik
mentality how so it's the the Americans
are gonna get a man in space first no
[ __ ] Sputnik was just there and it's
like we got a race to get these movies
out got a race to be the top but what's
doing is the quality suffering did what
on the DC side yes that's what I'm
saying
because and I think it is so likely so
they come out with this like Justice
League and could and I think they did it
just because where we got to compete
with the Avengers and it's like no you
have to build up who all these
characters are so you they did it with
Wonder Woman that was a great movie I
really enjoyed it yeah that's just me I
enjoy I didn't say that one oh I enjoy I
didn't see a lot of them so that you
know but I enjoyed Wonder Woman so she
was a great character it was a great
movie and then you have like now you
then you're gonna put Justice League
together and you have these characters
in a day
who's cyborg what's his story you're
this he was on an episode of Smallville
you're this weird flash you know he was
I just didn't like I love that actor but
I didn't like how you played it Eric you
know it's funny what I'm hearing you go
on cuz obviously you're a nerd like me
yeah but here's what's funny
what I never read comic books I was
never a guy that watched that stuff I
watched Superman because I loved gene
happening Christopher Reeve I'm a horror
movie fan that's what I watch and I
watch documentaries I've never when I
got Lex Luthor people were like oh my
god you must have been this mr. dennit
biggest dream I mean I didn't know
anything about Lex Luthor oh that's so I
think that's why it made me made it work
because I didn't watch movies and I
didn't look at anything I just said I
remember going play it real man play it
real learn the lines and I remember just
just BB Ruby you like the guy that
played Dumbledore he never read Harry
Potter and the people were furious with
was he great of course okay so I hear
what you're saying to me right now I was
like yo I'm not really a nerd like that
until I am a nerd I want you see no I'm
done see in terms of comic books and
stuff like that so I totally get that
but that's an interesting thing anyway
just the point I'm trying to make is
that it's just I think that they made
they they miss stepped in like what they
were trying to do to try to compete with
these things and now it's like it's all
scrapped it's like it's all yeah it's
all to [ __ ] and so they're gonna have to
start over again so but again maybe when
they start over again they're gonna be
like let's bring in rosin back do you
know what it is this whole thing is
Hollywood is built around fear everybody
who works in Hollywood they're working
for some producer even if they have an
idea they're gonna see what everybody
else thinks first and that's a lot of
unfortunately you know when these movies
are made like the last Jedi I like the
last one
yeah but JJ Abrams but they left they
had to fix a lot of [ __ ] but the last
Jedi the one before it it's just like
how someone didn't look at this movie or
read the script and go floating Leia
how that wasn't stopped it's just like
you know Bobbie Lee Bobbie lived in his
podcast the most four times but Bobbie I
love him Bobbie is like I think I've
been on it four times also [ __ ] yeah and
just so you know FYI
but like Bobby hates tattoo that she was
floating it's just like you know power
yeah are you a Star Wars nerd I am Star
Wars well we can we can - if did you you
know what do you think of these new
three what do you mean the new three of
the the Jedi I thought force awakens was
a valiant effort and I thought it was it
was fun and it was good and I liked that
you used Allah JJ used a lot of
practicals and it's felt fun it almost
felt like watching the first one again
but for newer generation and even like
for an older generation so there was a
lot of greatness in that the second one
just [ __ ] the bed yeah I don't I don't
even there's nothing to talk about
there's a guy that rants on it on
YouTube that is the funniest [ __ ]
thing it's him screaming and yelling and
commentating through the whole movie and
it is dead-on right
and and you know and then the third one
I was with a group of people and we
watched a couple weeks ago and I cried
and I go wow I like to get cry - okay
there was three times I cried now but
I'm gonna feel like this yeah but nobody
else really liked it and then a week
like a few days later they start with
their kids are they so whatever and they
all text make a Rosie I like it now I
love it so I think yeah I thought the in
now the mandalorian I'm not all caught
up but the more the merrier
you know the first three were great and
I felt like the next three were kind of
what I don't like is especially in
horror movies you don't need big stars
you don't need big stars in men Lauren
you don't need anybody you don't and in
fact I'd rather watch a bunch of people
that I'd never seen in my life before
because that's just cool because that's
what star wars lead check it out well I
just say so Jim and that's why you get a
different Lex for that same reason you
just said alright I agree with you that
that's all I'm saying that's a good
point
I'm not my whole point there you [ __ ]
you call you that maybe I'll do
something so crazy I guess so brilliant
that will go you know with him people
gonna like all I'm saying is your
thought process of why you want to see
no stars in mandalorian is the same
thought process of why when you're
starting something new and you want to
establish your own thing and so you
don't want anybody remembering anything
anyway that's all oh wait a minute that
you can chase Jesse Eisenberg but they
cast you know but he's but he always
what he's not in the universe it doesn't
even matter if that's a different
conversation you're talking about a guy
who's playing the nerd in this and
playing this and I know it's acting look
this is yeah I I know what you're saying
I don't disagree with what you're saying
but I don't agree with it I know it's
tough because I don't like that you
don't disagree but I don't agree with it
I know I think it's just for me I don't
wanna keep you going down that rabbit
hole so get back I kind of speak my mind
anyway I really don't give a [ __ ] I
really appreciate the back it's like you
know what if [ __ ] you're auditioning
first the new Superman you know I
I would if I had a studio just for shits
and giggles bring them all in bring them
all in respect I brought them all in so
they can say they tested it lasted for
it and it's also respect hey they had me
read yeah okay wouldn't it be good if
people really felt like that but there
are people out there that would they're
actors out there that would be like can
you believe that they asked me to
audition for a part that I played for
seven years there's a process there's
there's people that would think like
that - yeah so you can't win there's
nothing's beneath me I I don't know I'm
not saying you know you you're saying
bring me in I want to read right I'm
saying there are other actors who would
call that disrespect right so you can't
win for losing I think I was saying more
about like you know and I by the way
again I love Jesse Eisenberg it wasn't
like I'm not saying anybody em I'm just
saying you hate him no I don't I'm
saying that it's it's it's it's
contradictive you know it's
contradicting to say that you know well
because he's a name so if you're gonna
I'm saying okay if you want to go with a
no name great I'm saying mandalorian for
Star Wars for something that's so old
that's Sol yeah and there was like you
don't need to distract people with this
new series when you see like oh you know
I listen I know what you're saying but
let me give you another example I'm
friends with Dane Cook no we've had him
on your parkas I had him on mine he's a
buddy of mine but I remember talking to
him about I was on a show I'm dying up
here on Showtime it was about comedy in
the 70s face of the comedy store so I
was on that show and Dean was I was
talking with Gary yeah yeah I could tell
Dane was a little bit like he wanted to
be on the show right and I remember
saying to him you can't be on the show
cuz you're Dane Cook you know you know I
mean like when people see that no matter
how good an actor you are it's a show
about comedy and you're you're seeing
someone who was larger than life in
comedy and that's gonna be a hard you
know really cos Jim Carrey it's he
wasn't on the show he just produced it I
just produce yeah you didn't do some no
no that was his other show so yeah so it
speaks to what you're saying about like
you know you have in the mandalorian you
had cuz I was a no-name nobody really
knows who I was you know I mean it was
my first dramatic role you know what I
mean so it's like you know you had these
people who were like
not as famous because if you have
somebody super famous who is known as a
being a comic it's gonna be a hard thing
to like for when the people are watching
they're gonna be like oh that's you know
unless just shows about him you know
what I mean
so what I'm saying I know what you mean
about like when the Mandalorian or it's
like you know we don't know any of these
people you know we've seen someone
before like to do from Breaking Bad just
like I feel like you know he's like the
bad guy you have you seen all of them
but here's the difference here's the
difference this is gonna break your
point oh here we go the Mandalorian are
like 30 minutes long or something 22
minutes yeah the 22 minutes even less
than a random faces that show up the
reality is whether it's whoever's
playing a role in a movie everybody's
judging him the first 10 minutes till
that person whoever it is sells them
yeah yeah and when they sell in other
words if I was playing Lex and all sent
10 minutes and all that it wasn't that
the guy who played but it doesn't matter
if I'm great it doesn't [ __ ] matter
but when you're throwing 22 minutes at
them and then they're just seeing your
random faces show up it takes them out
of this world like some comedian or
something this it just kind of and there
it just just for me that's different
than someone portraying something and
then you getting to know him then you're
there with them and he has an hour and
40 minutes to [ __ ] but the
mandalorian they had that there's a
bunch of people I know on a Mandalorian
hey Sam he had bill burr mmm he was
great yeah I'm just saying that you know
they had the guy awesome he was great
you know there's people on there that
you like recognized and if you don't
think it takes you out of it all no
because it's kind of cool isn't because
Star Wars is such a nerdy thing that
it's kind of cool that you you got
you're going like oh here's this person
I know from here and we're plopping them
in the Star Wars universe so it's kind
of like interesting just look the I'd be
on Star Wars in a second so my you know
yeah it's kinda you know rocks I'll be
like what's Lex Luthor do but what Sam
Jackson doing what so they can name 50
million actresses oh by the way I agree
with you I thought that was all not like
listen there's only been three good Star
Wars movies Star Wars Empire Strikes
Back Return of the Jedi the rest of this
stuff is just being other sequels could
get just thrown away and people go not
about Seth I'm like no utter nonsense
just maybe rogue one that's cgi if you
watch it is
like oh my god I just can't do it but
again I think you know Mandalore is
great
I really do i watch it I like it it's a
you know this is like the job of stuff
they to me it's like that's what's that
Star Wars that's practical I'm seeing
the sandcrawler with these I love that
they use it a doll - oh dude and you're
like going oh my god I feel like you
know what it is it's a nostalgia for the
old guy yes that's it very much you know
I think a Seth Green's said something
once he goes because we taught my Jar
Jar Binks he goes I asked George Lucas
he said I asked George Lucas what about
charger Binks and he said I wasn't for
you it was for children like like c-3po
was for you when you were young it was a
really valid point yeah yeah I don't I
don't buy it go [ __ ] off [ __ ] off no no
no I'm sorry I'd tell them that myself -
you will you say Lucas [ __ ] yeah Luke
George Lucas [ __ ] off your your your
that was terrible you know what I mean
it was terrible is ego that's an ego
answer no you sucked in those three
movies you sucked as a writer you sucked
as a director you sucked sorry but he
gave let me tell you something right M
night Shyamalan okay one of my favorite
directors like you watching servant no I
haven't seen you you piece of [ __ ]
here's what I'm saying signs
I loved Village I loved me Sixth Sense I
loved but we need a bunch of movies that
everybody hated I'm like does that make
him a terrible director no no it doesn't
he's a great [ __ ] director who hasn't
made as great a movies as he did he
missed the mark so Lucas is still a
[ __ ] genius and he's way he ever said
he created something that we're gonna
dis gonna last forever I love him for it
as the Pope of Star Wars you know what I
mean but he did he had some those were
just [ __ ] up at the Mars he missed the
mark and sorry he and he needs till I be
like damn it I missed a mark on that
yeah for him to be like whoa it wasn't
for you it wasn't for anybody dude
nobody likes Jar Jar Binks
you know the whole movie was like full
of like weird racial things and weird
like stories the worst child actor in
the history of acting
okay Ascot and again I don't even have
to say you know exactly did guy I don't
even know how that guy got the part
like it's as if it's as if his family
has something over George Lucas okay it
was like they had a pain you have you
yes some I'm super nerd yeah because I
couldn't what I'm saying is you take
something that you love so much right so
like his Charles Storrs is from my
childhood I remember I remember Return
of the Jedi was the introduction of thx
sound so it was the first time I was in
the theater
yeah it was just like the most you know
how much money do you spend on Star Wars
oh do you know how much money I've spent
on action figures and even to this day I
actually I buy things all the time I buy
things I love Star Wars I just love it
and I have a buddy a lot mine like that
a comedian named Edwin San Juan he has a
roomful of Star Wars stuff he's that
he's a collector like that I'm not a
collector dicaprio owned the entire set
everything of the original trilogy
everything and he's like yeah I'm gonna
sell it this was years ago I remember I
was talking to him and I was like really
how much do you want to sell that for
but I think it was like a couple of
eight artists at the time you got drop
something talking like you know you're
bragging but it's like you meet people
you know I can't play a bond on the
Nintendo whatever with him all the time
he's I love him great good yeah that's
what yeah sure you met a lot oh we
didn't even talk about my podcast I'm
gonna bring it up so [ __ ] you up talk I
didn't use so much gold it was keys to
[ __ ] yeah we got like we got like 10
more minutes if you want to get a solid
out all right now I'm just about you
know I feel like I could [ __ ] with you
already
you can I feel like I've gotten to know
you cuz I didn't know you cuz you didn't
come really up to me and I was like
nervous and I was doing all my stand-up
yeah you know now I just feel like you
just don't want you to come back yeah I
like just talking about so what I feel
with you is like yes we're talking about
Lex Luthor we're talking about you know
this stuff but I feel like if we wanted
to talk about other things anything we'd
be able to get into a nice holiday back
and forth the people will go to a pod a
politics podcast and yeah go there they
don't want to hear this [ __ ] they want
to hear a couple of minions but yeah
this is what they want to listen to or
they'd go to politics.com or some [ __ ]
and I did I I didn't want to talk about
the the crazy chick from your show but I
guess we can just let it go we'll talk
about it another time yeah
Ikey probably talked about it ed Nog's I
really haven't I've cup kept things
closed theof on brought it up yeah I saw
that he kind of like I was impressed
that you went to his podcast dressed
like
a hobo I know yeah I didn't know is on
camera I don't even know a short song
yeah when you walked in right now I was
like thinking like what is he gonna look
like yeah maybe maybe I don't know man
um like so you have your podcast tell me
about your podcast all right look I mean
this goddamn you don't trust me with a
plastic knife oh you know I sure I'm
sure you've killed people with less
maybe I maybe you know it started out as
somebody was just trying to get me to do
podcast you do blog guys you gotta get
boys do a podcast deal but I guess I was
like man and I do it man you make money
people make money on my all right well
then I realized you know it's it's a lot
more difficult and I realized I didn't
know what I was doing in the beginning I
didn't really know what I was getting at
and then all of a sudden I fell in love
with it like I feel like if I could make
enough money doing my podcast I don't
want won't do anything else because I'd
help people I it's it was like I said it
was therapy for me you know and I talked
to Dane Cook and he's talking about his
brother and you know what you know how
he stole from him and I'm talking to
Jennifer Love Hewitt who doesn't love
herself and Kristen Bell who's depressed
and who has depression issues and I'm
talking about real [ __ ] I gotta drop a
lot of [ __ ] right I'm like Rainn Wilson
talking about like he's like you know I
don't I'm not my work
and I remember him stopping me like 40
minutes in and going hey um we haven't
even talked about the office I go you
want to he's like no yeah this is great
yeah so like I said I think it's become
something really special for me and the
fans must be tough for like someone like
that that's exactly what we were talking
about earlier though it's like that's a
sort of like even more iconic character
that like people will always reference
and right
it's like the kind place data on star
star track that guy's name yeah I know
he's talking about it because I was I
did blunt talk with Patrick Stewart you
know that's not sure I was my job yeah
you know I've worked this worthless drop
really piece of [ __ ] I don't know I was
on the mine so he was talking he's
always data you know people are always
coming up to him but then he goes you
know what though I got a big house in
Malibu
I got a you know so there's like the
there's the give-and-take of it well he
said but you try to be a human being and
it's hard not to be like that you know
well he was talking about rain was
talking about like because I was an
[ __ ]
and he talks about that and his you know
how he got through it and how he was a
perfectionist and it was always about
being great and I was like oh my god I
can relate to this please please many
therap many guests they've asked me like
Kevin Nealon is I feel like I'm your
therapist is this for you is this
podcast for you and I oh yeah yeah I'm
doing it because I learned so much about
these few people who by the way one
that's coming up uh an actress or
whatever had somebody had a panic attack
on my pocket oh and keeping it in that's
good cuz well I told this girl I said
hey I'll cut it but I think it's
important and they were like hey let me
come back and we finished it we talked
about it and it's gonna come up and it's
it's amazing
I had a comedian it's amazing she was
pleased that a comic on Angela Johnson
was on and she started to cry because
she was remembering a story of like you
know being like you know like a sort of
me to story you know yeah so I was like
and I just sat here and like what are
you supposed to do you know so it's like
yeah I mean I think there's something
there's something bonding about it
there's something like you know and I
think like being a performer being an
actor like who you are we we've talked
once in passing today man how are you
know honey oh thanks you know that's
about it right and then like I've talked
Bobby's told me about you by the way
Bobby said ah he's great you know so but
it's like you know you sitting here and
like I'm like hey you know I feel like
oh we've known each other for a long
time I don't know I used to worry
I don't want to sound like an ass I
don't wanna sell you this but just say
what you want to say and what you do
with so many podcast like you know over
and over like you know every week you're
like at this point how can i guard
myself you know what I feel like people
spend so much time holding up a mask of
like to not show who they really are
that energy they expend holding up that
mask if they would expend that energy
just being themselves
it would be a lot easier yeah no I agree
look man it's taken me a long time I
would get anxiety attacks on sets really
and no one would know and I play it cool
and it was it tormented me and it was
you know and and now I feel I'm at a
place where you know if I'm having an
anxiety or something I'm just gonna tell
everybody about it like hey yeah I feel
like I would look at you and go Erica
I'm having an anxiety attack right so
I'm a little uncomfortable I think I
could do that now and I think what that
does is it opens it up it opens up the
channels through to your listeners
thinking hey you know oh he had some sex
access and he you know he was Lex Luthor
oh he gets anxiety or you know the the
thing that we're sharing is we're just
being ourselves and showing everybody
that look we're not perfect or not you
[ __ ] the time it normalizes I think
it helps normalize mental health and
that's what I we talk about it on mine
so no mental health is like a big issue
um you know it's not it's it's more it's
fun it's like I ask questions I feel
like I asked unlike like Stern's amazing
he's the best in the world at this and
you know I just feel like I don't
interrogate people I just like to go
down wormholes like you know if there's
like you know my parents cool they're
like yeah well my dad was so anyway I go
no no what was with your mom and then we
still keep going down there and in a
comfortable way like I get you what does
that dude as a child with your
developmental stages how did you how did
that make you feel do you feel like that
has any and we start talking about stuff
and also in an hour goes by and it's
real and it's relatable and it really
doesn't matter about because people have
heard every story go go watch Kimmel if
you want to see somebody on late-night
television yeah yeah but if you want to
hear real [ __ ] this is what podcast can
be great you know well I feel like
you're even from from when you first sat
down
I feel like you're even more comfortable
from the beginning to now in terms of
like the questions and how we've been
talking about things cuz you know we
were your pleaser I can tell you know
what I mean you want you know I sure you
want to make people happy you want to
get they want and it's like my whole
life I've been doing that I'm learning
slowly to sort of decompress and go you
know let's let's think about what I want
yeah you know not all the time you got
to look out sometimes you got to just
you know and by the way this year or
that last year it was a big year for me
because it was like I am part of so many
charities now hands on I really think if
you want to change your life and change
others let's go somewhere where you
don't think about your [ __ ] self and
hang out with some kids who are going
through leukemia and do a movie night at
the Ronald McDonald House or go to food
on foot and you know stand with the
homeless and talk to them and watch
these organizations that really work and
help people and disappear from your you
know your [ __ ] life yeah and these
are the things that start to help you
and it's by being grateful dude and
everybody will say there's no sickness
secret is there's no secret the secret
is be grateful be happy with what you
got and I truly truly am and I don't
think I was always that way but I've
learned to to that's the only way to
live it really is if you want any
happiness you got to be grateful man I
appreciate that you know and I
appreciate that you you come came on and
talked about this that's a great way to
end I mean I just feel like it's a good
message you know I wish you all the best
I really I I we I have your number let's
you know you know doing the thing it was
a sneaky way to it was like call Erica
and he'll let you in come downstairs oh
you know what's funny about that it's
like when you like you know another way
people do this now they go like oh you
taking a picture Hickey text me that you
know that's what I love about airdrop
like you get my number
I never noticed this is something to
Bob's me this is a non-sequitur you ever
get a random taxes like what are you up
to
and then you say oh sorry I got a new
phone who's this cuz that's the excuse
me on your phone who's this I don't
believe that anymore and you have iCloud
and they don't respond or they you know
look at really and then they don't
respond at all and you're like what what
the [ __ ] dude yeah I have a [ __ ]
number
yeah who you are I didn't put your
number in my phone
[Music]
alright ladies and gentlemen I will have
all of Mike's information do you like
being called Mike or you are Michael guy
no uh you seem like a fancy [ __ ] my
friends call me Rosenbaum live people
cojiro Z Mike my dad calls me bought my
mom dad calls me Michael my mom calls me
Mike
I get Griff a lot of people gotta grab
ya because Eric Griffin they caught me
Griff for like you know eg you know it's
like it's like we get called a name and
then nobody calls us that name for the
rest of our life you know I mean ya know
I used to get carsick rosy palms your
kid like you let you jerk off yeah oh my
god is that bad I do am i I kind of like
roll you're gay
I like oh yeah yeah I used to think when
you're a kid and there's not like
internet or anything when I grew up is
like everything people say about you
dude
I was horrified wish we I didn't think I
would have been um I think I would have
been terrible if I had the internet when
I was fifteen
you masturbate you're gay just knowing
like no I'm not no I'm not Eric Griffin
masturbates like Oh that'd be on the
internet compulsively yeah okay you've
had you enough this is Michael Rosenbaum
and all his information will be below
check out his podcast side of youth
Michael Rosenbaum check it out side of
you animations I'll show you love and if
you're if you're gone cuz you can watch
Smallville on on some pretty much
everywhere if you want actually it's a
great watch I'm telling it's fun go
watch Smallville if you want to just
that's a great you'll you'll zip throat
and this guy was a fantastic on it and
let's start the you know Rosenbaum is
Lex again hashtag Rosa Rosenbaum reads
for Lex his tag
well they just take a little excerpt he
flipped out they didn't show me going
haha just kidding with you know that's
not what I meant
it's just know you people watch this
they're gonna know that you dear you you
were genuine I appreciate you can direct
your openness I look forward to having
you on again then I appreciate you
coming over to the west side of town
this is fun fix your leak fix your whole
was no it's not my leak they it's a
leakage you know
this might have my business on the
street okay how dare you
I'm gonna tweet your address right after
this yeah Griffin you want to go to two
five nine bungalow seven and you know
what by the way another another sequitur
or whatever you call it
non sequitur yeah I had a neighbor once
that was like just tweeted like guess
who lives in my building you know you
know I was like I tweeted back that guy
probably doesn't want and people to know
that like who are you doing no I don't
[ __ ] you is so ridiculous that people
just don't realize it like moms lives
here
but anyways thanks for watching me from
a Griffin please subscribe share and
I'll see you next week